expand or Die get big how did that
translate to you being here tonight well
this is what all the farmers told me I
spent six months with them and to me it
means a capitalism run amok it means the
housing crisis the banking crisis it
means Walmart smashing up Main Street
and it means a massive amount of
pressure on really good-hearted people
and that means tough situations and you
shot the film in DeKalb Illinois is that
right yeah DeKalb painfully Sycamore he
shot a little bit in Iowa it said in
Iowa were shot in Illinois and how did
the people of those towns embrace you
how I hear that they let you into their
homes and they were quite generous with
their time what wonderful people the
movie could not have been made without
them people like Kevin and Linda Herman
we shot on their farm the Sycamore
Speedway I mean thousand five hundred
extras came out of the goodness of their
heart to make the film and all the
farmers and everyone in those towns they
were so good and warm and hearted and
opening and I lived in their homes with
George Naylor and Troy Roush and rod
Pierce and I think it's just this system
at play this this economic system which
is making them and putting them into
very very tough situations and that gets
expressed through Dennis's character
that though
and lastly how did you get the big names
attached to this film what was your
process oh I watched YouTube yes and I
saw Dennis in The Ellen Show on YouTube
and I saw Jack on Jimmy Kimmel and I
turn the sound down and I thought they
looked so good and then I was lucky they
said he had and I got a real blessing
with the both of them and with all the
cats really Kim and heatherandmike good
Clancy is just really phenomenal
so you went through their agents or
managers and asked them that way to get
the script well Dennis his agent
contacted me and said what do you think
about Dennis ways for the film and I
said well I love tennis played is going
back to Breaking Away one of my favorite
films afar from heaven and the right
stuff in honestly then I watched him on
Google I watched him on Ellen and I
thought his improvisational comedy was
so good that I thought he do could be
very interesting and Zack had then read
the screenplay and I we're in the same
sack and I are in the same agency and so
I think someone had given him the script
and he had loved it so then he had asked
if we could meet and I said of course I
would love to meet you I had seen him in
Richard Linklater's film me and Orson
Welles and thought he was really really
good in it
and he just had a keen understanding of
the part he had grown up in a small town
not that different he actually
understood the parts so well that he
gave me some dialogue inadvertently that
I put into the script I didn't tell him
till later and I was just very impressed
by I thought he would be one thing
fakes of popularity but he was such a
grounded and flyed young man which is
very taken by him he has a limitless
future
thank you so much really appreciate it
thank you